wie lange soll der staat uns den
vorschreiben wann wir was zu tun haben
waren wir etwas zu tragen haben und wann
wir wie in welcher kneipe gehen würde
ich will nicht mehr in einer
bevormundung leben für mich ist das eine
bevormundung den ungarn in budapest wird
werden überhaupt keine masken getragen
und dort ist die instanz auf drei
gesunden ich bin was kroner betrifft
zuerst mal in meinem leben ziemlich
ratlos der staat darf nicht automatisch
verbieten was gefährlich ist wenn ich
nicht selber vor dem risiko schützen
kann aber genau dahin führt der inzidenz
wert 50 natürlich und wenn ich
frühzeitig die ausbreitung des virus
vermindern will was wird an dieser
stelle gesetzt
[Musik]
mein name ist julian reichelt und hier
ist viertel nach acht schönen guten
abend
bei uns geht es um die emotionalsten
themen der woche und was mich am meisten
bewegt hat heute ist das thema um die
inzidenz 50 die inzidenz 50 wird von der
bundesregierung nun endlich abgeschafft
in dieser corona krise die inzidenz 50
war von anfang an der falsche maßstab
den sie den 50 hat nie wirklich etwas
darüber ausgesagt wie schlimm diese
krise gerade ist 50 oder 100 infizierte
positiv getestet im studentenheim sind
etwas ganz anderes als 100 positiv
getestete im altersheim vor wenigen
wochen traf sich die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zusammen
mit bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und
diskutierte darüber ob man diese
incidents nicht abschaffen sollte sie
kamen zu keinem ergebnis warum nicht
weil das robert koch-institut auto
institut auch nach anderthalb jahren
panini es nicht geschafft hat einen
neuen tatsächlich funktionierenden
maßstab dafür zu entwickeln wie schlimm
diese krise in unserem land gerade ist
wozu führte das leere intensivstation
kaum patienten die wegen corona in
behandlung waren und trotzdem blieb
dieser wert blieb die instanz 50 jetzt
kommt sie endlich weg das ist ein großer
befreiungsschlag für uns alle denn sie
war nur noch da um quasi willkürlich und
zu gängeln mitbewohner maßnahmen und
hätte automatisch in den nächsten locker
und geführt gut dass sie weg ist ich
hoffe die bundesregierung geht bald
endlich den nächsten schritt und schenkt
uns das was es in anderen ländern zum
beispiel in großbritannien nämlich schon
längst gibt den freiheitstag ich sage
vor den freiheitstag der deutschen den
dritten oktober an dem alle maßnahmen
fallen ich habe damit ein problem wir
sind warum bei ich habe bisher noch
nichts gefunden was mir ein hinweis
darauf gibt dass sich das virus wieder
verstärkt verbreitet wenn ich heute nach
nordrhein-westfalen gucke da stelle ich
fest dass in nordrhein westfalen die
institute sind vier wochen um den faktor
7 gewachsen ist und parallel dazu habe
ich eine entwicklung bei den
hospitalisierten die vervierfachung sich
und weiß man dass das immer nachläuft
und wenn ich frühzeitig die ausbreitung
des virus vermindern will was wird an
dieser stelle gesetzt und ich glaube
dass wir das tun müssen denn ich nehme
den bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
sehr ernst der gesagt hat im herbst und
winter werden sich 100 prozent
derjenigen infizieren die nicht
geimpften und das ist eine schlimme
botschaft für unsere kinder und alle
kinder von eins bis zwölf würden nach
entspannen sich glauben wir das wirklich
es sind noch ungefähr zehn bis 15
millionen deutsche nicht geimpft glauben
wir wirklich dass sich innerhalb der
nächsten sechs sieben monate 12 15
millionen deutsche infizieren werden ich
glaube das nicht und ich war gerade in
ungarn in budapest wird werden überhaupt
keine masken getragen und dort ist die
inzidenz auf zwei gesunken obwohl die
leute sich draußen treffen zusammen
ausgehen und die maske ist ein vorschlag
und einige tragen sie wenn sie in der
straßenbahn fahren aber ansonsten
niemand also wenn es da gehen wir so
geht es bei uns nicht ich verstehe das
nicht also ich denke einfach dass diese
das mit corona leben müssen und
diejenigen die vorsichtig sind die
werden auch weiterhin vorsichtig sein
und diejenigen die nicht vorsichtig sind
werden das auch weiterhin so gut ist ich
muss ihnen erstmal absolute zustimmung
frau riekel für mich ist ja die maske
wirklich eine unverschämtheit also ich
bin doppelt geimpft und werden immer
noch gezwungen maske zu tragen ich muss
sagen ich möchte das nicht ich möchte
das auch nicht mehr von dem start ich
will nicht mehr in einer bevormundung
leben für mich ist es eine bevormundung
arbeit zu dem impfen noch mal vor allem
auch die kinder die angesprochen wurden
es gibt ja studien die belegen dass es
für kinder sogar weniger risiko halt
corona zu bekommen weil sie nur leichte
verläufe haben als eine impfung also ich
weiß gar nicht ob es so schlimm wäre
wenn die kinder sich anstecken würden in
den schulen weil die älteren die sich
schützen müssen können ja geimpft werden
also wenn jeder in impfangebot hat sehe
ich für meinen fall keinen einzigen
grund mehr warum überhaupt noch
bevormundung vom staat ausgehen soll das
war ja wir haben ja keinen impfangebot
und sie haben selber gesagt
werden nachher sagen sie möchten auch
niemanden dazu nötigen geimpft zu werden
und was mein argument war ein ganz
einfaches wenn ich verhindern will dass
sich das virus verbreitet und es muss
die entscheidung auch übrigens der
eltern bleiben ob mein kind infiziert
werden soll oder nicht ob man das risiko
was sie eben gesagt haben sei gering
eingehen will oder nicht und meine
einfache frage ist was hat man wenn man
die inzidenz nicht mehr als maßstab hat
um die ausbreitung des virus frühzeitig
zu unterbinden bevor wie es jetzt in
ordnung in westfalen sich abzeichnet die
kliniken mit infizierten von jürgen
trittin sagt auffällig oft nordrhein
westfalen sind daher kommt der krise hat
zufällig hatte das ist das ist in
anderen ländern genauso es aber nicht
wegen laschet aber wie lange wie lange
soll der staat und den vorschreiben wann
wir was zu tun haben waren wir etwas zu
tragen haben und wann wir wie in welcher
kneipe wären würde ich bin ja gar nicht
darum dass ich bin mich interessiert die
ideologische debatten ich glaube
eigentlich eher und die frage wie
unterbinde ich eine schnelle ausbreitung
des virus weil die schnelle ausbreitung
des virus hat eine andere folge nämlich
das auftreten auch von mutationen des
sie muss ich selbst wenn ich viele
geimpfte haben interesse haben dass sich
das virus möglichst nicht unkontrolliert
verbringt für mich nach impfquote 100
prozent weil der wir dann werden wir
werden dann hierhin kommen das weiß ich
auch aber eine verlangsamung eine
verminderung der infektion ist etwas was
bisher aus epidemiologischer sicht
richtig warm ein punkt inzwischen
minimales risiko minimales risiko dass
man sich dass man einen schweren verlauf
hat wenn man sich selber zu einer
impfung entscheidet ich würde immer
sagen der staat darf nicht automatisch
verbieten was gefährlich ist wenn ich
mich selber vor dem risiko schützen kann
aber genau dahin führte incidence wert
50 natürlich weil er ein automatismus
ist der immer da der maßnahmen auslöst
der dazu führt dass der staat mir dann
vorschreibt was ich tun darf und was ich
nicht und ich würde sagen dazu gibt es
inzwischen nicht mehr die gefahrenlage
und ich frage mich auch wie soll diese
gefahrenlage eigentlich enden wie gesagt
irgendwann 80 prozent bei 90 prozent bei
95 oder wenn das allerletzte kind dann
auch noch geimpftes bin ein bisschen
zurückhaltend da war ich diskutiere zb
bei mir im wahlkreis seit einem jahr
darüber dass in den schulen die nicht
gut gelüftet werden konnten teilweise
kann man die fenster nicht aufmachen
endlich luftreiniger eingeführt werden
das heißt diejenigen die unter der
schulpflicht in die schule gehen müssen
haben gar nicht die wahl und da habe ich
eine verantwortung zu sagen ich möchte
nicht dass ich dieses virus
unkontrolliert verbreiten ich hab mich
teile manche kritik an an der seinen
blanken incidents ich habe nur die frage
gestellt was setzt man an der stelle
dagegen und wie sorgt man dafür dass es
nicht zu einer unkontrollierten
ausbreitung kommen weil diese
unkontrollierte ausbreitung ist da nicht
mehr meine privatsache sondern ich habe
auch eine verantwortung die gesellschaft
hat verantwortung für andere und
insbesondere für kinder der blick aus
amerika thomas gottschalk der inzwischen
ist der blick leer aus deutschland und
ich bin was corona betrifft zum ersten
mal im leben ziemlich ratlos erstes mal
sehe ich mich natürlich auch als opfer
was man ja relativ leicht kann im sinne
von um gottes willen werde ich das
überleben aber ich sehe mich als geimpft
auch in irgendeiner form privilegiert
und ich war gerade in einer situation wo
ich also ohne masken ein kaufhaus rein
gerannt bin aber ich wollte nur bis zu
einem stand wo kein mensch in der nähe
war und wollte mir das angucken wollte
um dann gleich rückwärts wieder
rauszugehen und da bin ich der
eigentlich immer gemacht hat was er
wollte plötzlich in einer art von
ängstlichkeit und sagt habt ihr hier
masken und dann kommt einer will sich
fotografieren lassen dann sage ich ja
ohne maske mit maske ich bin geimpft das
ist mein liebster satz in letzter zeit
ich bin geimpft aber er bringt mir
relativ wenig aber ist das nicht
furchtbar dass man sich auf einmal
rechtfertigen muss für ein komplett
risikofrei essverhalten es passiert ja
nicht wenn sie an einen stand ohne
menschen sie können jemand ansteckend
sie können sich nicht anstecken
ja aber es ist etwas was einen in
irgendeiner form gemacht ich bin was
corona betrifft nach dieser zeit die wir
jetzt in dieser band emil leben mürbe
ich wollte nach amerika ich kann da
nicht hin das heißt ich könnte weil ich
eine greencard habe aber meine partnerin
kann nicht und man hofft immer dass was
passiert aber es passiert nichts dann
kriegst du natürlich immer wenn du so
ein bisschen den kopf zu stellen ist
wieder eins drüber ja als die data
variante jetzt kommt noch eine variante
also irgendwo hat man den eindruck dass
man so ein bisschen h immer wenn man
denkt es wird besser wieder ein auf die
nuss gekriegt und die inzidenz geht
höher und ich gucke natürlich immer
diese karten da an wo du jetzt wieder
merkt hoppla jetzt wird wieder alles
bunt war schon mal grau war dass das
ängstigt mich ja nicht an den corona
maßnahmen sondern
zum beispiel jetzt wieder in china
passiert was sind austragen was
neuseeland passiert das ist ja nicht
alles folge von irgendwelchen maßnahmen
sondern das virus dies halt noch nicht
beherrscht und es wird erst dann
beherrscht sein wenn wir es weltweit
bewerbe wir werden es nie ganz
beherrschen also corona ist in der welt
und wird auch in der welt bleiben und
ich glaube wir müssen damit leben und
wir können doch nicht deswegen unsere
ganze wirtschaft unser ganzes soziales
leben einfach beenden das ist also das
finde ich ein riesiges problem ich bin
auch geimpft habe ich verstehe menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen weil
einfach noch nicht klar ist was diese
impfungen in unserem körper verursacht
und wenn ich kinder hätte würde ich sie
nicht impfen lassen weil ich glaube dass
kinder dann noch viel sensibler
reagieren und das ist zu kurz um um alle
menschen zu beruhigen die sagen ich habe
angst
vor dieser impfung also ich verstehe das
und ich bin gegen einen impfzwang und
ich finde einfach menschen die
vorsichtig sind die werden das auch
weiterhin sein und andere werden es eben
nicht sein die sind auch während des
lockouts sind viele menschen eben nicht
vorsichtig gewesen und das werden wir
auch nicht ändern können die saßen an
der isar gruppen jugendliche weiß wohin
gehen dürfte nun haben sich
das bier eingegossen und saßen da einen
großen horden solange bis die polizei
gekommen ist jetzt wieder vertrieben
dann sind sie wieder woanders
hingegangen also auf diese weise werden
wir das nicht besiegen
[Musik]